[Applause]
oh [ __ ] how many of y'all believe in
aliens
i think there's some aliens for real how
many y'all believe
smart [ __ ] rescue y'all
arrogant as muffa
you know what i'm saying cause you got
to be out your [ __ ] mind to think
we're the only [ __ ] in the universe
you know what you look at all the
diverse life on this one planet
birds snakes alligators lions tigers and
bears oh boy
i mean look at the diversity just
amongst human beings you know i'm saying
like god gonna create all this life here
and then just say all right everything
else will be lights
light it up for him at night you know
saying hell yeah some [ __ ]
aliens out here reason they don't come
here bad news travel fast
we known throughout the universe as the
[ __ ] up planet
that's why [ __ ] say they seen
the ufo they don't say it land landed
came in the house i cooked it dinner
y'all said them [ __ ] ain't
landing
[ __ ] they be on the spaceship man this
is probably just the [ __ ] up planet
tour they get a little pamphlet and [ __ ]
cause 500 cougars to come to this
[ __ ]
[ __ ] sitting on the spaceship
looking out the window hey come on let's
go down there let's mess with them
shut the [ __ ] up they fight over black
and white we purple what the [ __ ] you
think they gonna do to us
now look your ass out the window let's
go
bro what's scarier ghosts or aliens
ghosts or aliens [ __ ] aliens this is
an easy one yeah deal
ghost what's the worst they can do i
don't know [ __ ] with my lights
might pull my sheets back okay cool man
somebody told me once in a dream that
aliens are gonna come here and fight
black people was that crazy or what
did a white person tell you that no i
don't remember who it was but
by aliens i mean otherwise well that
there's a low-key beef between aliens
and black people
they're called mexicans what
yeah bro i don't think so dude who told
you this
no maurice claret told me the most
dangerous people in prison are mexicans
that they
are the most dangerous people yeah the
most dangerous
it's coming from a black guy so no
somebody told me there's beef between
black people and
aliens dude i'm not a black person i'm
not insider trading here i don't know
so let's go to our let's go to our
ethnic friends that are here right now
are you assuming cats or derrick are
scared of aliens because they're black
i don't know if anyone's scared of them
i'm saying is there a low-key beef
between ethnicities
that aren't white i'm white i don't know
we have beef against certain things
what don't we like we have what do white
people have beef against
i would say probably money taxes water
slow internet um
i don't know what current white
princesses are no a lot of white people
like them
i don't think none of the whites hang
out with that's true me neither
what do you think there are you scared
of aliens i just want to know theo did
you get that information from
the movie independence guys did you see
will smith
a blade punch an alien you're like oh
there's beef between these smells it
could have been
aliens and he's kind of the leader yeah
i remember what i was watching but i
fell asleep and had a dream that
and and then it started to resonate with
me that there is
a low-key thing going on between black
people and aliens that
and i wouldn't know about it and he you
wouldn't know about it you know i think
when you refer to aliens you mean
mexicans i think that's what's going on
no i'm talking about aries illegally
i'm talking about air aliens oh you're
talking about like area 50 sky aliens
yeah
you know what i'm saying so derek you
ever heard of this
so-called beef i mean no
theo okay i'm not accusing anybody just
one black guy though said it so that's
where you get to them
you know well i'll tell you that the
first time black people
uh have a lot of early information
because first time i learned about flat
earth i was at a pizza
place a late night pizza [ __ ] spot at
a casino oh yeah he told me this
and two black dudes said hey man we
gotta talk to you right and i thought
you know
[ __ ] was about to go down you know like
they were gonna run a train on you
no oh you thought you were gonna beat
you up
i didn't know i wasn't sure i thought
we're gonna do that or gamble together
talk about [ __ ] racial pro
dude hey can we talk about oh my god
don't hit me then
well no dude we'll talk about flat earth
well that's what they did they sent me
another visa parlor
and which is irony because you're in a
pizza parlor right and so the pizza that
whole setup
and that's the way they said look man
look at this pizza what do you think
about it
and i was like it's like they said is it
round and i said i mean it's round but
they're said but really it's flat
and they but did you and then they these
two dudes explained to me flat earth and
i'd never heard it before
and then years later flat earth comes to
be this big thing
you know they just you know you know
they're doing all a flat
big thing for dummies but yeah i guess
it's a big thing big name for thinkers i
think
but now to hear that black people and
aliens are against each other
again i i don't know if that's real
that's what i'm trying to do
those might be the same flat earthers
i'm not hiding it from you theo it's not
i don't know where you got that from
okay i believe you okay there might be
some truth there though but i think
you're
i think you're a little confused and are
you hearing anything on your front cat
about aliens and black people no aliens
what about asians and aliens yeah
oh asians hate other asians i know that
okay
well i'm glad we got that out of the way
well damn
yeah wow they can't stand other asians
you know what's crazy though is you
never hear asians with conspiracy
theories or
aliens they don't give a [ __ ] stories
you have a lot of ghosts really
like you have that ghost forest or
whatever the [ __ ] we're like um yes
there's ghosts there
sure yeah well that's logan paul did
that
yeah i know and i think yeah he killed
his brother over there something what
happened
they stumbled upon the video dead
brothers
oh yeah well look man i think jesus
don't [ __ ] with the conspiracy theories
in like flat earth [ __ ]
they're too busy make making [ __ ] what
do you mean making [ __ ] dude what do you
mean dude
what do you mean you're the one wearing
all the [ __ ] they're making i know so
are you it's made in america
no it's not it is no
uh i'm way more scared of aliens [ __ ] a
ghost what's the worst thing a ghost can
do to you ghosts can haunt you ghosts
can
possess your grandmother cool give her
some energy
ghost can live at your grandparents
house forever yeah they just haunt old
people
i'm amazed we haven't seen as many
ghosts recently as there were
in l.a there's no ghosts i i definitely
need to see that the comedy store
go to the belly room turn the lights off
shit's definitely haunted
that's a guy feeling on you dude is it
is it the same guy every time
[ __ ] damn
i thought it was a ghost um i thought it
was a gay ghost but yeah i'll go aliens
because they're like the bigger ghost
they're like ghost daddy
you know and we don't know what they're
doing they're out there they might come
by they might not
but dude i'll tell you this i'd watch a
group of aliens and a group of brothers
[ __ ] throw down any day of the week
yeah
you keep going back to aliens versus
black guys and i don't maybe because i
heard it
would be a fun video but i heard early
information
aliens versus black guys the video game
yeah i'd play that dude
don't touch all right ufos dude my
question is in here somewhere
i am nowhere near a conspiracy freak or
anything like that but i do admit
i get a hard on for any documentary on
that secret military base in nevada that
is called area 51.
the government is supposed well i mean
believing in
aliens like i i don't know
that that's really not that crazy
you know you think like how big the
[ __ ] universe is
there's just life on one planet no life
anywhere else despite the fact that they
see evidence of water on mars
at some point you know i'm telling you
guys we're not that special
if you're god and you made the whole
universe are you i'm just gonna sit back
watching one [ __ ]
planet maybe that's why the earth is so
[ __ ] up i don't think he's been
watching us for the last couple thousand
was the last time he reached out
reach out reach out and freak someone
out
right when's the last time he [ __ ]
did that was the last time he [ __ ]
was in a burning bush going hey hey you
there you there with the long [ __ ]
curvy stick next to the sheep
come over here come over to the burning
bush you know once last time he did that
i think he's been watching other earths
um
flipping through the channels you know
can you imagine how clear his [ __ ]
how big do you think god's flat screen
tv is
how clear is that picture i bet even if
you make it to heaven
you know you don't even get to see it
like he comes out of his office and you
try to peek in real quick
and like the human eye you get just it's
just too much of a [ __ ] glare right
um
so anyways yeah if you believe in aliens
i mean
i mean i don't know that that we can
reach one another
you know that whole flying saucer
[ __ ] horseshit mean
how long can you go with with artificial
breathe you know
some sort of atmosphere in there that
was like on star trek i mean they just
had this limitless supply of [ __ ]
oxygen
just [ __ ] flying through space
they now look at them they landed on a
lot of planets that had oxygen they
would just land on these planets and
they just had oxygen i think what they
did was
they opened they landed the starship
enterprise and they just opened the
windows and they got some more oxygen
and then they flew away right
isn't that how it works
anyways the government supposedly is
housing
and researching crashed ufos and uses
deadly force
to keep regular people out do you have
any opinion on the subject i think i
just said
i mean i don't [ __ ] do i think they
actually have the bodies of aliens
um
do you realize like the level of secrecy
you would have to have if you actually
had that [ __ ] that would be like one of
the things before they went in the room
it's like okay
we're gonna let you in this room and
you gotta understand when you go in this
room the door is closing and you're
never getting out
because you're gonna see some [ __ ]
[ __ ] in here that i don't give a [ __ ]
you're not if you have one shot of
nyquil
you're gonna be blabbering about it
you can't do it so i i don't know
i don't [ __ ] know um anyways he goes
what does your [ __ ] meter say i
think there's way too much of a veil of
secrecy around the place to think
otherwise
i used to know someone who was a career
air force pilot whenever the subject of
that base or
those mysterious flights mysterious
lights over phoenix
scene in 1997 came up he completely
removed himself from the conversation uh
those mysterious lights i don't even
know what you're talking about for all
you know they're just
testing some psycho [ __ ] weaponry
you know remember when the new yankee
stadium came out
in like 0.8 or 09 and they were like we
have 2013
technology all right if those [ __ ]
morons that run that place
can have [ __ ] that we're not gonna have
you know they can be four or five years
ahead of us can you imagine what the
government
is i mean they gotta have [ __ ] from like
i don't know
2014. i i have no [ __ ] idea i don't
know
anyways he says uh quite frankly the
evening's lapse would end
right after the topic was brought up i
believe in life outside of our universe
to think that we human and all of
earth's inhabitants so the only life
anywhere is just plain ignorant i 100
agree with that
i'm sure you've heard stories about
president nixon secretly showing ufos
and aliens to his favorite comedian
jackie gleason
uh that's a complete crock of [ __ ] uh
what would you
like he's gonna do that all right now i
know i'm not supposed to show you the
i know i'm not supposed to show yourself
and away we go
that was a bad nixon impression right
there um what would happen if you were
shown some stuff like that i
imagine i would immediately be
microchipped or shot in the back of the
[ __ ] head
would you tell about it i wouldn't want
to know about that
that if i actually found out about that
it would blow my [ __ ] mind
i you know what it is look maybe that
maybe your air force guy
buddy there has seen something because i
would say that like all converse
no but you know what he laughs right up
until that moment
if he wasn't laughing at all throughout
all your conversation
then i would i would believe it more
because i know if i knew some [ __ ] like
that
and then i would sit there and listening
to people talking about god
and holy [ __ ] that we believe down here
that didn't include
aliens i would i would feel like a
[ __ ] alien
because i would be like uh yeah we're
just a speck of dust bear people
and there's all this other stuff out
there and uh
yeah it would drive me nuts after a
while this whole thing about aliens
and that we know there's aliens like the
government but the government's made up
of people
so you think there's people out there
that see aliens and they just keep it to
themselves they go
home hey we got a secret here hey i know
there's aliens but
i'm i got my [ __ ] together where i don't
say this aliens
you know what you know why because
people think those people that know
are constantly in brick windowless
buildings what about when he's at a
cookout with his family or something
[ __ ] that's when it would come out
and they got brains and they got big
eyes
like it's like oh like these dudes are
so
like the president knows there's aliens
keeping this secret
from little stupid us he's not picking
up the phone when he's in his secured
like office gotta use this swipe card to
get into and going
yes there's aliens i see him they're
here in the building when he's bowling
sweetie how was your day today
[ __ ] i can't i gotta tell you this one
just make mistake
all right don't tell nothing don't say
[ __ ] sweetie don't tell your dumb
friends at work
these [ __ ] got big eyes and four feet
it's alien talk for years but i've never
seen a conspiracy
there's no aliens they've never seen
them they don't have them
no somebody would it's just too much for
a human being to deal with bunch of rats
that's all we are we love right you want
to be the guy that tells something
even if the guy you know he saw aliens
you know what makes it
funny in my my stupid thinking is you
know he still has to wait uh for a table
at a restaurant
if i just told this guy you would think
you could pull out that card and they'd
be like yeah that's great
it's still a half hour wait i don't give
a [ __ ] but you don't understand i've
seen the aliens i think the alien you
think you hint like
i think i could get a table i drove all
the way from roswell
to uh come to your place roswell new
mexico